as the chauvin jury begins its
deliberations the media ratchet up the
racial tension
and maxine waters pushes violence in the
streets as democrats defend her
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't like big tech and the government
spying on you visit expressvpn.com
slash pen we'll get to all the news in
just one moment first a quick reminder
if it feels like things are quickly
spiraling out of control that's because
well they kind of are if you look at the
inflation rates and commodities right
now they are extraordinary it's
something the media don't want you to
pay attention to but if you care about
your financial portfolio you probably
should there's only one great way to
protect your savings do it over 10 000
other smart investors have done convert
a portion of your retirement accounts
into gold and silver with birch gold
when inflation hits and it already is
gold and silver are your safe haven
birch gold group those are the people i
trust
help you convert an ira or eligible 401k
into an ira backed by gold and silver
through april 30th on qualifying
purchases when you open a precious
metals ira with birch gold
they'll send you a free home safe birch
gold those are the people i buy my gold
from and you can trust them
as well text ben 247 4747
for your free information kit on
precious metals ira or to speak with a
birch gold representative
today again with 10 000 customers i've
got an a plus rating with a better
business bureau countless five star
reviews you've heard me talk with the
representatives here
on the show they're the people that i
trust for my own precious metals
investing and they can help you as well
text ben
to 47 47 47 for your free safe with
qualifying purchase today alrighty so
the world is now on edge as we await the
verdict in the derek chauvin trial the
jury is out
the jury was issued closing statements
by the prosecution and by the defense
then there was a prosecution rebuttal
yesterday and then the jury were
sequestered now they should have been
sequestered all along the fact that they
weren't sequestered
is a real problem because it turns out
that this is the most publicized
high-profile criminal trial in the
united states probably since oj simpson
this this thing has has taken up
enormous sums of time and energy
it's created protests and riots in the
street for the
for the last year and now only now did
the judge decide it was time to
sequester the jury and that was only
after
everyone on the jury knows the base and
gross truth here which is that if they
don't
convict then their name is going to be
on the front page of a paper
probably two weeks from now and then
their life will be ruined
if you are on that jury i have a lot of
sympathy for you frankly because it
takes an enormous amount of bravery
to simply look at the evidence and the
facts in the case and come to a logical
conclusion
and there are a couple of logical
conclusions here now i could certainly
see
a conviction of derek chauvin for
manslaughter i think it's almost
impossible not to see reasonable doubt
when it comes to the second and third
degree murder charges manslaughter is a
lower standard
because it suggests reckless disregard
for the life of another
and so you can make the case that even
if chauvin originally wasn't doing
anything particularly bad
once floyd went unconscious he should
have gotten off of him that's an easier
case
than the notion that he was committing a
felony assault against
against george floyd on purpose or the
case that he caused george floyd's death
not by denying him care after he was
already unconscious and staying on top
of him but through
his actions alone frankly i find it
extraordinarily difficult to believe
that the simple pressure
of of derek chauvin's knee on george
floyd's back not on his neck on his back
because this was again testified to by
prosecution witnesses
is that the body cam footage showed that
chauvin's knee was not in fact in
position
to cut off either george floyd's airways
or the oxygen flow to his brain
if that was the case then you are
suggesting a 140 pound man with 40
pounds of gear on him
kneeling on the back of george floyd for
about nine minutes was enough to kill
the six foot five
240 pound george floyd without any sort
of intervening circumstances and people
who are testifying on behalf of the
prosecution basically said that which is
quite crazy to me the idea that the the
drug
fueled behavior of floyd
for the 16 minutes prior to the nine
minutes that we've all seen
on tape that had nothing to do with
anything that george floyd had enough
fentanyl in him to kill a horse had
nothing to do with anything the fact
that 75
arterial blockage that that had nothing
to do with anything the
that's the prosecution's case that's
very difficult to believe again the
prosecution had a heavy burden here
because they have to get you beyond a
reasonable doubt right it is not just
that they have to prove
by a preponderance of the evidence which
is the standard in civil court you know
like a majority of the evidence you
think
probably it's choven's fault it has to
be beyond a reasonable doubt that this
is chauvin's fault and it has to be
shown a couple of things one
that he did not act as a reasonable
police officer should have and two
that he's the actual causative factor in
george floyd's death it was a
substantial
factor in george floyd's death there's a
great analysis over legal insurrection
which has been doing excellent work
covering the day to day on this case and
one of the analysts over there
was writing about sort of the
differences in terms of the causation
arguments being put forward by the
prosecution in the defense
the prosecution is is essentially
arguing that this case
is akin to a man is on a
is on a subway platform and a mugger
comes up to him
and pops out of the shadows and scares
the guy and the guy topples backward
onto the subway tracks and then is run
over
is the mugger at fault for that okay so
that would be the substantial factor
right without the mugger there without
the monger having scared the guy
he he would be fine and what the defense
is arguing is that this is more akin
to somebody like a normal person on the
street
encountering a police officer and the
police officer
trying to arrest the person and the
person dropping dead of a heart attack
was the police officer a substantial
factor
in that person's death the defense is
arguing well really not because
it was the underlying causes that were
the greatest factor
in the death if the if the arrest merely
sent up the heart rate like it would for
any normal person and this was a
particularly
susceptible suspect then that removes
the causative factor okay so that's
factor number one the reasonable
police officer stuff is all about
whether chauvin did something that is so
outside the realm of what a normal
police officer would do or reasonably
reasonable police officer would do that
he deserves to get 10 years 15 years 20
years in jail for it
and there again they have to prove
beyond a reasonable doubt that chovin
acted
with a certain level of recklessness if
you want manslaughter
or that he acted with a direct intent to
felony assault george floyd which again
is a super hard case
as eric nelson the defense attorney kept
pointing out chauvin knows the body cams
are on he knows he's being filmed
the the notion that chovin is is just
committing this felony assault in front
of people because he desperately wants
to kill george floyd or because it
doesn't care if george floyd dies
is sort of counterintuitive considering
that shoving was a many-year
serving police officer on the four so
this is not his first rodeo exactly
but the prosecution laid out its final
case yesterday the defense laid out his
final case yesterday
the prosecutor's case was very much
rooted in emotion and
i have to say i think that the the judge
in this particular case judge cahill
the way that he ruled on a variety of
issues presents serious issues for
appeal
we're gonna get to maxine waters in a
second because that is a serious issue
for appeal
but there are many situations here where
it seems like there are serious issues
for appeal number one
third degree murder should not have been
on the docket here third degree murder
does not apply
third degree depraved heart murder is
not the right charge here because
depraved heart murder
requires that your malice be directed at
others your recklessness be directed at
others not at other
right other looks like manslaughter
others where you fire a gun into a crowd
knowing it's probably gonna kill
somebody that's depraved murder that
charge didn't apply
cahill reinstated it but he shouldn't
have allowed a full week
of witness testimony that was entirely
non-probative
this is first year evidence in law
school you do not allow evidence as a
judge that has nothing to do
with whether the case is true or not all
it has to do with is how bad you felt
about the case
all that is is prejudicial and when you
see on tv people say that
certain information is prejudicial to
the jury what they mean is that it is
not relevant or pertinent
to the guilt or innocence of a
particular party in the case
just as it would have been prejudicial
to simply talk about george floyd's
criminal background
without any reference to the case
because it didn't have anything anything
to do with the case
it is absolutely prejudicial to have
witness testimony on how upset they
personally were and how they couldn't
sleep because they saw george floyd died
that's true for for presumably tens of
millions of people who saw the tape of
george floyd dying in the first place
so none of that should have been allowed
in court that's going to be an issue on
appeal
there will be issues on appeal for sure
with regard to
the treatment of the jury by outside
forces
it's my contention that this case never
should have been held in minneapolis in
the first place this is like a perfect
textbook case of when you transfer venue
minneapolis is the site it is the
epicenter of racial conflicts in the
country right now
it is the epicenter of all attention in
the country right now
and it is made up of a jury the the
jurors are members of the community who
are going to have to deal with all of
that fallout
which of course makes it very difficult
to have a fair and impartial jury of
your peers if you are derek chovin
so there can be a lot of issues on
appeal here okay so the prosecutor laid
out his case and what i was going to say
about the prosecutor's case
is that it was very emotionally laden
most of the prosecutor's case
was not about laying out he went on for
a couple of hours most of his case
was not about laying out the
fact-by-fact
moment by moment timeline of what
happened with chauvin and floyd because
that actually doesn't cut in favor of
the prosecution
most of it was about the the basic idea
that if you just watch the tape you know
exactly what happened
and that of course is not the whole
story as the defense said
so here is the prosecutor concluding
with uh i don't know
something from dr seuss's the grinch
here we go
you were told for example
that mr floyd died
that mr floyd died because his heart was
too big
you heard that testimony and now having
seen all the evidence
i haven't heard all the evidence you
know the truth and the truth of the
matter is
that the reason george floyd is dead is
because mr shulman's heart was too small
okay i mean that that's very emotional
and it's gonna make a lot of
tweets light up with with joy but is
that really a value to the jury
i mean again the the case for
recklessness
the case for outright malice is pretty
low here the case for
felony assault i still think is kind of
low the case for recklessness you might
be able to make on a manslaughter charge
but but this sort of
you know emotionally laden stuff i don't
know
it doesn't say anything probative to me
what the prosecutor did do when he was
discussing the charges he put up a chart
of the charges against chauvin
explaining the elements of the various
crimes this chart actually
is useful to understand what exactly is
happening in the case so
murder in the second degree there there
are four elements one the death of
george floyd has to be proven okay well
he's dead so that would be proven the
second element is that the defendant's
actions were a substantial causal factor
in mr floyd's death the fact that other
causes contributed to the death does not
relieve the defendants of criminal
liability okay so
this is where i was talking about the
disagreement on causation the defense is
going to argue
substantial causal factor means that
it has to be the chief causal factor
right there can be other things that are
involved
right just like in the case that i was
mentioning before where the robber jumps
at the mugger job instead of you on the
subway platform it's the subway that
kills you if you fall off and somebody
runs you over
but the mugger is the substantial chief
factor in your death
because it is his fault that you got
frightened and fell onto the subway
tracks okay well the the prosecution is
arguing something different which is
that if you are just
any factor almost in in the death of
somebody then this means that you're
guilty i think that that's
kind of unsustainable on the legal basis
the third element of murder in the
second degree is that the defendant at
the time of causing the death of george
floyd was committing or attempting to
commit the felony offense of assault in
the third degree
saying the defendant assaulted george
floyd intentionally applying unlawful
force to floyd without his consent
resulting in bodily harm
and the defendant inflicted substantial
bodily harm on george floyd both of
those elements are in doubt
because again there was no actual
autopsy result showing that there was
damage to george floyd's trachea for
example or that he was deprived of
oxygen to his brain specifically because
of the because of the the so-called
suppression hole that was being used
on george floyd and the notion that he
was using a form of suppression hold
that was not allowed by minneapolis pd
is not true it was in the minneapolis pd
playbook
final element the defendant attack took
place on or about may 25th 2020
in hennepin county okay so murder in
second degree i think it's very hard to
meet all those standards murder in the
third degree
again has five elements two of them are
the same right you have to prove that he
died you have to prove when he died
okay but then and the substantial causal
factor element
is the same as well murder in the third
degree says the defendant caused the
death of george floyd by an intentional
act that was eminently dangerous to
other persons but it wasn't eminently
dangerous to other persons that's the
entire thing
right so this this charge does not apply
at all i think he can't prove second
degree
i think third degree just does not apply
then you get to manslaughter in the
second degree and this one is a lot
looser
here you just have to show that the
defendant caused the death of george
floyd by culpable negligence whereby the
defendant created an unreasonable risk
and consciously took a chance of causing
death or great bodily harm and here you
don't have to intend that your conduct
be harmful
all you have to do is be reckless and
this is where the defense was focused in
on the crowd right that their defense to
this was
chauvin was distracted by the crowd he
didn't know what was going on under his
knee because
again he's not looking down at george
floyd he's you can see in the tape he's
yelling at the crowd the crowd is
yelling at him yeah she reaches for his
mace
and all of this okay so that's the
prosecution's case i think that it is
very very weak when it comes to the
murder charges i think that it is
more arguable when it comes to the
manslaughter charge meanwhile eric
nelson
the defense attorney he made his case he
said
that floyd's death beyond anything else
it just was not chauvin's fault just not
on a
root factual level you ca this chauvin
was not
the substantial factor in in the death
of george floyd
and again this was always the strongest
case on behalf of the defense
and frankly it's a very plausible case
that basically ends the case
in my view again you don't have to
believe this you just have to
is this reasonable doubt sounds like
reasonable doubt to me again i think the
base
medical fact pattern here which is that
george floyd was high as a kite had
three times the deadly amount of
fentanyl in his system
had a 75 arterial blockage
it's extremely difficult for me to
believe that that is not a level of
reasonable doubt that applies to the
causation factor
in all of the charges i could see a jury
going the other way on manslaughter
but they really would have to ignore
this here's here's eric nelson talking
about this this is the defense attorney
for derek shobin
you have to be convinced that the
defendant's actions
caused the death of mr floyd
and throughout the course of this trial
the state has tried and
called numerous witnesses to try to
convince you that asphyxiation
is the singular cause of death
the singular cause of death and why is
that
it's because actions that happened
before mr floyd was arrested
that had nothing to do with officer
chauvin's activities
are not the natural consequences of the
defendant's
actions and again one of the things that
the prosecution never really proved is
that if
george floyd was already saying i can't
breathe if he was already
in the midst of a medical issue then
chauvin was not that you've caused a
factor in his death and if you jumped if
you fell down on the subway tracks and
then the mugger shouted at you
at that point it's not even the mugger's
fault if you get run over by the train
it's sort of the case that the defense
was making here
now here is the amazing thing about this
i'm trying to present this with as much
nuance and detail as i can in a short
period of time and we've gone through a
lot of the details in the case in a way
that you haven't seen in much of the
mainstream media
the establishment media do not want to
present you the details of the case the
establishment media think it is a sin
for you to know what the defense has
been saying in this case because the
establishment media are rooting for
riots
i cannot see any other reason why they
are presenting the case in the light
they are presenting it
they are dedicated to the narrative that
america is deeply racist and that if
derek chovin is acquitted it's because
of deep american racism and they are
justifying and excusing rioting and
looting
and anybody who justifies and excuses
rioting and looting
they will simply poo-poo and pretend
they're not doing it it's it's it's an
amazingly
anti-american citizen thing to do you're
damaging actual americans
who are who have a right to expect a
level of peace
in their communities you are damaging
them by your establishment media
coverage the assessment media is
the way that they have ratcheted up the
tension here the way that they have
fostered the notion that if the jury
goes the wrong way here the jury is
therefore racist
and that if an individual juror sees fit
to
find reasonable doubt in these cases it
must be that that's yours life will be
ruined i mean honest to god it will take
a person of extraordinary bravery
to actually examine the facts in this
case which is why
my prediction is that the jury will will
hang on the on the murder charges and
probably come out in favor of
manslaughter
just my personal opinion could go the
other way but
we're going to find out in short order
but it's the media coverage that is
really the bigger issue here because no
matter how this trial goes
and yes i understand that a man's life
is at stake and a man's life was at
stake a year ago
when george floyd died but now derek
joven's future is at stake whether he's
going to spend the next couple decades
in jail which is
a major issue obviously when it comes to
the broader national issue
the broader national issue is that the
media have a stake in fomenting division
in the country that is going to end with
more violence and more looting
and more rioting unless they get their
way it is a form of political blackmail
that the media are now engaged in with
the american people
they're engaged in a game of political
chicken and they're using other people's
businesses
other people's livelihoods other
people's very lives
as tools in this game and it's quite
disgusting we'll get some more of this
in just one second first
let's talk about your sleep quality so
if all that is going to keep you up at
night worrying about it well let me just
recommend
you get a great pillow i'm talking of
course about my pillow well now
my pillow has gone even further not only
have they created the best pillow on the
market they've also created
my slippers the slippers took over two
years to develop they're designed to
wear indoors and outdoors all day long
both my wife and i
are in my slippers nearly all the time
when we are at home the my slippers are
made with my pillow foam and impact gel
to help prevent fatigue they are made
with quality leather suede i can tell
you firsthand these are very comfortable
you will love them i'm wearing them all
the time the whole family's gonna want
to make a fantastic gift for a limited
time
my pillow is offering 40 off their new
my slippers that is 40
off so now i've got sheets pillows and
slippers from my pillow like all of
their products comfort
is key everything they make is just high
quality stuff go to mypillow.com
click on the radial listener square use
promo code dailywire
you'll also get deep discounts on all my
pillow products including the giza dream
bed sheets the my pillow mattress topper
the my pillow towel sets or call 800 951
7160 that's 800-951-7163
use promo code dailywire visit
mypillow.com right now or call
800-951-7163 to get started
okay so when i say that the media are
fomenting
all of this that the media are are
treating this case
as an as a foregone conclusion or what
should be a foregone conclusion
just so that people lose their minds if
it goes the other way
they're being perfectly obvious about
this they're not even hiding the ball
they're not even trying to hide the ball
so for example here is cnn's senior
legal analyst laura coats on twitter
she tweeted out quote defense begins the
closing by defining reasonable doubt
not with why derek chovan is innocent
think about that
so in other words the defense is
admitting that derek shoving
so no sane jury could find that derek
chovin is not guilty now here's the
thing
the senior legal analyst at cnn i don't
know why she's the senior legal analyst
if she doesn't know
the simple fact that defining the
standard of reasonable doubt is what
defense lawyers do
in every single case of which i am aware
in a criminal trial
you always start with defining
reasonable doubt so the jury understands
what standard
the prosecutors have to prove if you're
trying to argue innocence then it
becomes a preponderance of the evidence
case then it's just okay is my case
better than his case but
the prosecution has to prove beyond a
standard of reasonable doubt and yet
there you have cnn's senior legal
analyst
suggesting that it is some sort of sin
for the defense to point out the
standard this means of course that the
client
is guilty meanwhile you have don lemon
on cnn your objective news reporter and
boy what a bleep show don lemon is
my goodness and don lemon was never
great but the evolution of don lemon
from basically anderson cooper into joy
reid has been astonishing to watch over
the past few years
he is just an openly partisan hack at
this point he has not even
i mean he frankly he makes sure we look
like a sometimes here was don
lemon yesterday suggesting that this was
straight up murder
we all know exactly what can happen when
a black man or woman's encounter
with police goes wrong every black
person in this country understands the
anger the grief
the helpless feeling in the pit of your
stomach
when it happens again and again and now
it's all coming to a head
in that jury room in minneapolis where
prosecutors
today called on jurors to believe what
they saw with their own eyes
saying this wasn't policing this was
murder
this is and of course don lemon isn't
just reporting what the prosecutors are
saying saying what they saw with their
own eye you saw it
you saw it forget the defense there's no
need to look at the tape it sounds like
chelsea handler here
right saying that you don't need to
present a defense when we all saw the
tape
except that you do and when don lemon
suggests that every police encounter
between black americans and police
officers ends
with the black person being mistreated
hurt
murdered by the police i just there's no
statistical evidence to support this
i don't know how many times i have to
say this anecdotal evidence is not
statistical evidence provide
the data provide the data demonstrating
that this is not due
to the offend the offences committed by
the suspect it is due
to police racism explain like let's have
that argument you want to hear that
argument let's talk about specific
police departments and we can break down
crime by crime what happened in each
case but they don't want to do that
the whole idea here is that you take a
data point even a data point like this
one that is awkward and doesn't really
fit the narrative
of a racist murder and then you turn it
into a racist murder for purposes of
suggesting that black people are
properly suspicious of all of white
america
because white america is shot through
with white supremacy the only cure for
which
is to provide unending
revision of the american bargain by the
federal government
that's really what's at stake here this
is all just a lever for change
and i don't mean change with a good sort
i mean a complete revision of the
american bargain between individual
rights
and the body politic and the media are
fomenting this again i can't
i can't emphasize this enough the media
are actively fomenting this
maxine waters who has been promoting
violence mass violence in the streets
for as long as she's been in public
politics i'm going all the way back
to 1992. this is a piece from the los
angeles this is from the new york times
circa 1992
talking about the rodney king riot
it's talking about maxine waters here it
says until three weeks ago the freshman
democratic congresswoman was little
known outside the washington beltway and
among those who follow california
politics are black politicians but since
the acquittal of four white police
officers in the beating of rodney king
set off the worst civil unrest this
century mrs waters has had a lot to say
and not everybody likes it
more than any other political leader
representing la more even than mayor tom
bradley mrs waters seemed to be all over
the airwaves acting as a voice of the
disenfranchised after unrest broke out
going all the way back by the way the
media were very warm toward the idea
that riots were simply the voice of the
dispossessed
she scared some people and angered
others by focusing on justifying
rather than condemning the violent
reaction to the verdict
and this is typical maxine waters
i mean maxine waters has she called the
la riots
in which by the way south central los
angeles which was largely black was
burned to the ground in large part
in which korean business owners were
targeted she called that an la uprising
in la uprising she says
i said in 101 different ways violence is
not right then i don't condone violence
that people can't endanger their own or
others lives what i didn't do is use the
airwaves to call people hoodlums and
thugs for burning down their own
communities
it only makes them matter when you call
them hoodlums and thugs the president
did
oh so that you're not you're not
justifying what they're doing you're
just saying they're not hoodlums and
thugs when they burn down their own
neighborhood
got it and she's been doing this her
entire career this is nothing new for
maxine waters
you'll remember just a couple of years
ago when maxine waters said that trump
administration members should be
actively
physically confronted whenever they go
out in public here's maxine waters just
a couple of years ago
you see anybody from that cabinet in a
restaurant
in a department store at a gasoline
station
you get out and you create a crowd
and you push back on them and you tell
them they're not
welcome anymore anywhere
and the left has not only tolerated this
they've celebrated this for a while
maxine waters was considered persona non
grata inside the democratic party
because she was deeply corrupt she was
on the financial services committee and
there were serious questions about
the financial services committee was
directing resources to
banks in which her husband was involved
and she was consistently considered one
of the
most corrupt members of congress but
during the trump era
she became anti-maxine again right she
was the person who was going to be
promoted
by the media as the person who could
speak truth to power trump didn't spring
out of a vacuum
guys i know that everybody wants to
think on the left that trump killed
american politics
trump was a symptom he was the coroner
he came along and he noticed the body of
american politics with the knife still
in it
and then he said oh this body has been
stabbed he didn't heal it
but he certainly didn't start it maxine
waters pre-existed trump
as a prominent person in american
politics as an elected official
by some almost 30 years
and yet maxine waters has not only been
tolerated she's been celebrated she's
been elevated inside the democratic
party for
most of that time with brief periods of
respite
okay so maxine waters of course the
other day she broke curfew she traveled
from washington dc to minnesota right to
minneapolis
to be there presumably to intimidate the
jury because why the hell else would you
be in minneapolis there were protests in
washington dc2 you could just protest it
out there
she flew into minneapolis just as al
sharpton has now flown into minneapolis
a race baiter who himself has been
involved in the incitement of riots
and maxine waters then told black lives
matter that if they didn't get what they
wanted
not just a conviction on manslaughter
she said there has to be a conviction on
murder charges
and then she even suggested there should
be a conviction on a charge of
first-degree murder which is not even
charged in this case
she said that if they don't get what
they want then they should quote unquote
get more confrontational well
i don't know what more confrontational
means in the context of a city they
nearly burned down about a year ago
so here is maxine waters telling blm
just the other day what she wants to
happen if she doesn't get her way if the
jury doesn't go her way which
is like pure simple jury intimidation
we've got to fight for justice but i am
very
hopeful and i hope that we're going to
get
a verdict that to say guilty guilty
guilty
and if we don't we cannot go away what
should protesters do
well we got to stay on the street uh and
we've got to get more
active we've got to get more
confrontational
we've got to make sure that they they
know that we need business
so all of this culminated yesterday with
judge cahill who again is a former staff
he was appointed by minnesota governor
tim pawlenty originally was a republican
but
he's a former staffer for amy klobuchar
right so the guy is not some sort of
crazed right-wing conservative and as
i've mentioned
the judge in this case has made a series
of decisions which i think
set up the possibility of a serious
appeal even if chauvin is convicted well
the judge yesterday was asked by nelson
from a mistrial on the basis of waters
comments and the judge said well i'm not
going to grant a mistrial but certainly
this is an issue for appeal
i wish elected officials would stop
talking about this case
especially in a manner that is
disrespectful to the rule of law
and to the judicial branch in our
function
i think if they want to give their
opinions they should do so in a
respectful
and in a manner that is consistent with
their oath to the constitution
to respect the co-equal branch of
government
their failure to do so i think is
abhorrent but i don't think it is
prejudiced us
with additional uh material that would
prejudice his journey
okay so the entire left went insane how
dare the judge say this
how did no one on the left i can't find
a single prominent figure on the left to
condemn
maxine waters for this sort of language
so the same exact people who said that
donald trump
who said that people should peacefully
protest what was going on on january 6th
at the capitol building and then a few
hundred droogs decided it would be a
wonderful idea to break into the capitol
building and threaten lawmakers
the same exact people like maxine waters
who suggested that donald trump was
guilty of incitement of an insurrection
are out there actively defending maxine
waters today or at the very least
poo-pooing it
so spare me your hysterics about donald
trump's fraught language
i didn't like his language but he said
peaceful
maxine waters has never said that sort
of stuff maxine waters
is one of the worst actors in congress
and you guys will never disown
your own your own radicals it's it's
fairly impressive
truly for the democratic party you have
to admire the solidarity
i've been told over and over by friends
of mine who are democrats look at these
republicans and how they have all these
people in the republican party who are
wild and crazy
and and they won't condemn anybody and i
just think to myself
well pretty much every time trump said
something that was that i thought was
bad i condemned him publicly
and many other people condemned him
publicly too when there were candidates
who were so thorough going bad that i
thought they should not be in congress i
helped run them out of congress like
steve king in iowa
right or like roy moore in alabama when
was the last time you saw the democrats
expel anyone
when was the last time the democrats
looked at maxine waters and like you
know what we don't like this
can you find anybody to go on record
about it whenever
whenever somebody on the democratic side
of the aisle is incredibly radical
or foments violence even if you're
somebody who participates in rioting and
looting i mean first of all kamala
harris
will contribute to your bailout fund in
minnesota but beyond that
if you are if you are a radical inside
the democratic party circles the vision
of you
is not the way it is in the republican
circles if you're in republican circles
and somebody is radical and crazy and
spouting conspiracy theories
there's a general sense of embarrassment
and like that person has bad ideas
if you're in democratic circles and
you're bernie sanders you're a wild eyed
socialist or if you're aoc
you've never had a good idea in your
entire life but you're very very loud
if you are if you are a democrat like
maxine waters who's fomented violence
then the entire democratic party will
rally to your cause
and declare that the real problem with
you is not that you have bad ideas it's
not your ideas are great
the real problem with you is that you
just have the pure naivete of a small
innocent child that's really the reason
you're such a bad person is because
you're actually super innocent
and you don't understand that this isn't
how politics works you gotta let the
adults work it out sweetheart but the
reality is that you are just so innocent
and so pure you're the best of us
you're not the worst of us you're the
best of us and that's the way the
democratic party treats their own
radicals inside the house
so kevin mccarthy the house minority
leader
he slammed waters he says water sees
value and violence which obviously is
true
uh here is the house minority leader and
then we'll get to the democratic and
media reaction which is to pretend that
maxine waters actually didn't say what
she just said and you watched her say
maxine waters believes there's value in
violence this is the first time she's
done something like this
remember what she said for in the past
administration for people to get in
their faces
to to to challenge everyone and now what
she has said
has even put doubt into a jury you had a
judge
announced that it was wrong i think this
takes action especially when she has a
pattern of this behavior
that of course is exactly true but what
did nancy pelosi the house
the house speaker have to say about
maxine waters what did you have to say
remember this is the same nancy pelosi
who watered down a resolution to condemn
ilhan omar's anti-semitism into a
resolution condemning all the bad things
and then took a trip with ilhan omar to
demonstrate solidarity
now she was asked if water should
apologize quote
no she doesn't maxine talked about
confrontation
in the manner of the civil rights
movement oh really is that what she
meant
because uh how would they get more
confrontational how
i mean seems like blm did 2 billion of
damage
across the course of the last summer how
do you get more confrontational was that
the manner of the civil rights movement
because i feel like nancy pelosi should
know better since she was alive for it
she says i myself think we should take
our lead from the george flayed family
they've handled this with great dignity
and no ambiguity or lack of
misinterpretation by the other side no i
don't think
she should apologize so no apology
required by nancy pelosi requested by
nancy pelosi john saki over at the white
house
he's asked about joe biden's view on
maxine waters comments and here's jen
sackey completely dodging the question
does the president agree with what she
said about getting more
confrontational well i can speak to the
president's view
he has been very clear that he
recognizes the issue of police violence
against
people of color communities of color is
one of great anguish
and it's exhausting and quite emotional
at times as you know he met with the
floyd family last year and has been
closely following the trial as we've
been talking about
and is committed to undoing this
long-standing systemic problem
okay so um if you recall the original
question was what do you think maxine
waters comments
not can you quote jonathan k part's bad
column in the washington post about
exhaustion
and meeting with george floyd's family
and a bunch of read out talking points
all he had to say was maxine water
shouldn't have said that it's bad that
she said that
we abhor all violence and maxine water's
contribution to
raising the temperature is not useful
that's all she has to say she can't say
that because the democratic party is
very much in favor of this inside
outside game whereby you get people in
the streets
actively participating in rioting and
looting an anti-police activity by by
the way uh
i know it's not a national story because
again national stories are just stories
that back the media's
establishment narrative hey i know it's
not a national story but somebody did
ambush a minneapolis national guard
person the other day
but that's not a national story guys not
a national story at all
the same day by the way i believe that
maxine waters made that comment doesn't
mean they incited it
doesn't mean that she's responsible for
that it does mean that um
she's not helping for sure but don't
worry the media are there to defend
maxine waters remember donald trump is
solely and completely responsible for
the
acts of january 6. the maxine waters
who's been actively fomenting violence
since the moment she set foot in
congress
she's never responsible for anything
that comes out of her mouth in fact
the stuff you heard her say she didn't
actually say here's don lemon saying she
wasn't inciting violence i take this at
face valley because don lemon is an
objective news source
do you really think maxine waters is
calling
for violence maxine waters is not
calling for violence
everyone knows that she makes a lot of
people uncomfortable especially a lot of
men and quite frankly especially
especially a lot of white men because
she puts him in her place
she tells you shut up respect this
person
don't talk to me that way and she gives
it to you like it
is now that said
do i think what she said was
constructive absolutely not
i love it all she speaks is the truth
all she says
are true things when she's not being a
corrupt windbag from california who
brings home the bacon to her husband's
banks
she all she says are true wonderful
incredible things she's anti-maxine now
so i think that was super constructive
no but she's
unbelievable and if you don't like her
it's cause you're a white man that's the
only reason that you wouldn't like
maxine waters going to the middle of a
trial zone
and standing like next to the courthouse
basically and saying
if they don't give you what you want
then you should get super
confrontational like more
confrontational than you've been in the
past in a city that nearly burned down a
year ago
don lemon objective journalist these
people
they want the conflict they want the
conflict they think the conflict is good
they think that the conflict makes the
country a better place i have a question
since the black lives matter movement
began what in america has gotten better
can you name a thing i just want one
name one thing that has gotten better
since the black lives matter movement
began
has gotten better for black people in
terms of violence in their cities
absolutely not it's got significantly
worse
has it gotten better for black people in
terms of inequality which is the
supposed main concern of blm
no it has not has it gotten better
in terms of race relations in the
country with all of these
posturing white left wingers in in
suburban areas kneeling on tape in front
of black people has that has that made
race relations in america significantly
better
can you feel america getting healthier
do you think that that black people are
more optimistic about race relations or
less how about white
people is is a single thing better than
it was in terms of race relations in the
united states than it was in say 2009
when barack obama first took office
the answer by every available metric is
no
no and yet the media are fomenting this
they are pushing it because
no matter the the the casualty list
on the other side no matter the damage
done all that matters is the utopia they
see
in their adult brains that's all that
matters and if they have to twist the
data if they have to twist the narrative
in order to get there they will
they don't care cnn did this all day
yesterday defending maxine waters all
day
the same people who say margery taylor
green is the biggest issue inside the
republican caucus this backbencher
from georgia who created a caucus for
anglo-saxon
cultural defense that had no members but
that was the biggest issue in america
you've got an active congresswoman who's
been promoting rioting and
violence literally her entire career
doing it again
the other day in the middle of a trial
so bad that the judge
again a person who staffed with amy
klobuchar
the judge said this could be a mistrial
issue and the democrats say no she's
wonderful it's great and the media are
right there with them
we'll get some more of this in just one
second first let us talk about the fact
that if you like your hair you really
have to work on keeping it right now i
know dudes
you think you can wait until you're 40
45 and then you can start worrying about
the hair loss here's the thing
by the time you hit your mid-30s you're
already starting to lose your hair you
really need
for hims.com it is your one-stop shop
for hair loss and wellness for men
hymns is helping dudes be the best
version of themselves with licensed
medical providers and
fda approved products to help treat hair
loss hymns was created by a guy
who knows that some men's health
conversations are easier online than in
person
no more awkward in person doctors visits
or long pharmacy lines four hymns
connects you
to licensed medical professionals online
that could save you hours completely
confidential completely discreet
answer a few quick questions a medical
professional will review if they
determine it's right for you
they can prescribe you medication to
treat your hair loss it is shipped
directly to your door today
hymns is giving you their best offer yet
if you're not happy with your results
after 90 days
hymns will give you a full refund and
right now my listeners can get their
first visit absolutely free
go to for hymns dot com slash ben that
is for hims.com
prescription products require an online
consultation with a healthcare provider
who'll determine if prescription is
appropriate restrictions applies the
website for full details and important
safety information
remember that is for hims.com ben
or we can get some more in just one
second first it's almost time for
another new episode of candace
this week's special guest is the awesome
dana white president of the ultimate
fighting championship ufc
the largest mixed martial arts
organization on planet earth the show
streams on fridays 9 pm eastern 8 pm
central only at dailywire.com
you can get 25 off a new membership with
code canvas get the audio podcast canvas
on apple spotify
or wherever you listen to your podcast
so if you need some candice owens in
your podcast feed
look no further head over to apple
podcaster spotify subscribe today be
sure to leave a five star review if you
like
what you hear you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
the ongoing defense of waters by the
media it is consistent yamiche alcindor
who's not a journalist she's an activist
for pbs
she tweeted out don't worry maxine
waters didn't threaten violence eric
nelson is now using representative
maxine waters saying that protesters
should quote get more active and more
confrontational if derek chovin isn't
convicted as a reason for a mistrial to
be declared he's claiming she threatened
violence
fact check waters did not threaten
violence weird because what she said was
way more violent than anything that
donald trump said on january 6th
weird i don't remember yamiche alcindor
feeling the same way
here's the thing cowards are going to
allow this to happen
towers are going to allow the rioting
and the looting to happen
as i've said the most important thing
that we are watching right now is the
simple real-time change in expectations
in the united states there's now an
expectation an
expectation you have it i have it we all
have it there's an expectation that any
time
there is a a an incident between a white
police officer
and a person of color that is caught on
tape no matter the surrounding
circumstances no matter whether the
suspect is guilty
of the crime or not no matter whether
the suspect resisted arrest that it will
result in riots and looting
there's a full-scale 100 expectation
sometimes on rare occasions
maybe the expectation is disappointed
but rarely but rarely
this means that we have now ingrained
bigotry with regard
to a certain percentage of the
population that we believe is now
justified in whatever they do
without data without even evidence in
particular cases
that is a very bad thing and you're
seeing our politicians take advantage of
this presumably for political gain so
you see brooklyn center's mayor saying
it's not safe to drive in minneapolis
while black not safe to drive in
minneapolis while black at all
okay due to what due to what due to one
incident
presumably he's talking about the dante
right incident in which a suspect
attempted to flee the police there was
an active warrant out for him
and then the police officer quite
obviously made a horrible mistake and
now will be tried for manslaughter and
now it's not safe for any black person
to drive anywhere in minneapolis
according to the brooklyn center mayor
you only say this kind of crap because
you're interested in the political gain
here's the brooklyn center mayor saying
it
this is something that people in my
community have been
grappling with for a very long time it's
not safe to drive uh
uh minnesota while you're black i mean
the fact of the matter is
there's so many of us who drive
you know and and and if we see uh police
behind us we're we're afraid you know
we're trembling and
that is a kind of terror that no
no citizens of the united no citizen of
the united states you ever have to face
okay
anytime you want to talk about the
terror faced by citizens who are having
to face down rioting and looting
that have been plaguing your city you
can do that too or you could talk about
the terror that faces ordinary black
americans
in most of america's major cities
because the police are just not in those
parts of town
you can talk about that because your
chances as a black american getting shot
by somebody who's not a police officer
are way higher than your chances
of being shot unarmed by a police
officer i mean by
several orders of magnitude to
minneapolis as mayor who's a joke
right this doofus you'll remember him
from such
from such wonderful tape as i'm going to
go down to the george floyd rally and
get shouted out for being a white racist
even though i'm trying to just
demonstrate my feel to you to your
overblown cause yeah i mean this guy's a
tool bag of extraordinary proportions
here's minneapolis mayor saying that
floyd no
no matter what the jury finds lord is
killed at the hands of the police and
then you say you're not justifying
writing you're literally saying that the
system is stacked against
the prosecution of a murderer because of
race but don't riot guys the system is
going to work on your behalf
the the sheer moral coward of the
cowardice of this is
pretty hard to exaggerate here here's
minneapolis as mayor
regardless of the outcome of this trial
regardless of the decision made by the
jury there is one true reality
which is that george floyd was killed at
the hands
of police oh is that the one true
reality because
i noticed that that was what was in
dispute in the criminal trial that's the
mayor of minneapolis how can you say
that there's not a mistrial here i don't
understand
how can you say that the jury has not
been prejudiced by the fact that the
mayor of the city
is saying that the cops killed george
floyd maxine waters is outside saying
you need to get more confrontational
with people
more than last year when you burned two
billion dollars worth of stuff and
killed a bunch of people
you get more confrontational than that
if you don't get what you want
how in the world was this trial taking
place in minneapolis in the first place
again i'm not even saying that you
couldn't make the case that children
should be convicted on manslaughter
i think that one is a 50 50 coin flip
but i do think
that there is no possible way to read
this as anything other than grounds for
mistrial when you have the minneapolis
the mayor of the
of the damned city is out there saying
that no matter what the jury finds they
are wrong if they don't find like i say
these politicians are craven they are
cowards they do not give one good god
bleep
about the about the facts in any
particular case they don't care about
the lives at stake they don't care about
the policy
his city has seen an exponential rise in
murder and crime over the course of the
last year
the corner where george floyd died has
become an epicenter of crime according
to the new york times that guy is the
mayor of that city
and his chief concern is continuing to
run down the police on the basis of a
conflicting set
of fact patterns it's unreal
there's only one thing that can that can
justify this sort of behavior and that
is
in pursuit of utopia everybody for the
left is either a tool or an obstacle
derek chauvin is a tool and an obstacle
for these people
due process is a is an obstacle for
these folks individual rights are an
obstacle and maxine waters is who
is a tool therefore maxine waters will
be defended and due process will be
thrown out the window and you're just
supposed to eat it
but guess what the american public at
some point is going to stand up on their
hind legs and say enough of all this
because it is horrifyingly bad for the
country alrighty we'll be back here
later today with an additional hour of
the ben shapiro show coming up soon
is the matt wall show it airs at 1 30 pm
eastern be sure to check it out over at
dailywire.com i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wydowski
editing is by adam science audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant is jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021.
on the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show